It's,
it's fitting that the first poem of
Milton's that we study in this class is on
the morning of Christ's naitivity.
And in a number of ways, it's both.
It's both the first poem and
it's a poem about firsts.
It isn't exactly though the first
poem that Milton that Milton wrote,
the young Milton. As you can see from
your, uh, from actually any addition,
any modern edition of Milton,
which arranges the poems, uh,
more or less chronologically,
you can tell that the young Milton had
actually written quite a few things
before he wrote what we call a
colloquially the note the naitivity owed.
But most of these early
pieces are written in the,
in the Latin that Milton
had perfected at school.
And these, these, these earliest, uh,
these earliest of Milton's
Latin poems are our lyrics.
There are of a highly
proficient technical, uh,
incredibly impressive
technical proficiency and they
are absolutely soaked with
the references to the classical writers
that Milton had been ingesting from,
from his earliest youth.
Milton had also written a couple of very,
very short poems in English.
But there's a,
there's an important and I think a very
real sense in which Milton wanted to
make it seem as if the naitivity owed.
We're the first poem that he had
written. And there's also, uh,
an important and I think a very real
sense in which Milton wanted to make it
seem. And obviously this is
a much more difficult feat.
Wanted to make it seem as if the naitivity
road where the first poem that anyone
had written now, now Milton
was born in 1608. And uh,
he wrote the naitivity owed
along with the sixth LG,
the LG OLED GSX data that we
read for today in December of 16,
29,
uh,
a couple of weeks presumably
after he turned 21,
it wasn't until 1645 at the age of 36 or
37 that Milton would publish his first
volume of poems, which he, which
he titled Simply Poems. And,
and it wouldn't be another 22
years after that until Milton, uh,
actually published paradise lost.
Now I'm,
I'm mentioning these dates here because
the dates on which Milton wrote and
published his poems, the, the
temporal sequence of these,
the publication,
it has a p peculiar and particular
importance to to Milton as early as 1629
that's that. That's
the date we're in. Now,
Milton is thinking of himself as
a poet who has not yet published.
He delays for an unusually long time,
his poetic entrance into print and he's
musing almost continually on on what it
means to be a poet who has,
who has delayed his publication
to be a poet, who's,
who's waiting for something to be a poet,
who always looking to the future,
to the poem that, that he hasn't yet
written down to the future to the readers.
He hasn't yet attained and maybe most
gloriously to the poet who was looking to
the future,
to the fame that he has not
yet successfully secured,
were secured at all because
no one at this point knows,
knows John Milton when in 1645 Milton
finally publishes that first volume of,
of poetry.
The first poem that he places in this
volume is the negativity out our poem
today and s and under this title on the
morning of Christ's naitivity appears,
as you can see from your text appears
the subtitle composed 1629 and Milton's
taking pains here and he does this,
he does this with very few other poems.
He takes pains to let us know precisely
when it is that he's written it a
composed 1629 whether or not
that's actually true and there's,
there's some, there's some controversy
about that. But nonetheless,
the subtitle announces to all who know,
John Milton that the poet was 21 years
old at the moment of its composition and
that he had therefore
just reached his majority.
Now,
the subject matter that he's chosen for
this poem for this so called first poem,
couldn't possibly be more
appropriate. Uh, when the,
when this with this first poem treating
the subject of the Nativity of Christ,
Milton is able implicitly,
uh,
to announce something like his
own naitivity as a, as a poet.
And it goes without saying that
there's, there's, there's just,
there's something outlandish
to say the least about this.
We're struck by the arrogance implicit in,
in Milton's active identification here.
What could possibly be more presumptuous
than the Association of the beginning
of one's own career,
one's own literary career with,
with the birth of the Christian Messiah.
Um,
Milton's implicit connection between
his own birth as a poet and the birth of
the son of God is inactive of Hubris
that I think a lot of his contemporaries
would feel more comfortable calling.
Uh, actually calling blasphemy
Milton's is, uh, John Milton.
We'll remain unique in English letters
for the degree of thought that he gave to
the shape of his literary career or
actually to the notion of a, of a,
of a career at all.
No English poet before Milton,
I'm ever suggested that he was,
that he had been chosen by
God at birth to be a poet,
Chaucer, Spenser, Shakespeare.
These are all pre miltonic poets.
None of these earlier figures had dared
to suggest and it would never have
occurred to them to suggest that
there's was actually a divine vocation.
It takes your, I think it
takes your breath away, uh,
to think of the unspeakably high
hopes that John Milton had for his,
for his career. If you have a chance,
you might want to take a look.
I think this is in the cross campus
library at the Facsimile version of the,
of the very first edition of Paradise
lost. It's in 10 books rather than 12. Um,
it's a, it's a, it's a modest thing, not
the facsimile version but the actual uh,
1667 volume and that the
text looks perfectly ordinary
until you realize that in
the margin alongside the lines of the
poem are printed the line numbers for,
for the poem,
just like the line numbers in any modern
edition of Milton that's been produced
for the likes of you, for the, for the
consumption of college English majors.
As far as I know, um, I,
I know of no exception,
although someone may well
be able to produce one,
no original poem in English had ever been
published with the line numbers in the
margin.
And it's very first in its very first
printing and it may well be that that no
poem has ever been since
Paradise lost published, uh,
with line numbers in its,
in its very first addition to any right
thinking printer or any right thinking
publisher would scarf at the presumption
of a poet who had demanded such a thing.
The only precedent Milton would
have had even for the idea of,
of line numbers, um, would, would
have been the great ancient classics,
the magnificent renaissance
additions of homer and Virgil. Um,
they would have appeared in the 17th
century with line numbers because line
numbers obviously facilitate the
production of scholarly commentary and
facilitate the study of
those texts in the classroom.
And I can only assume that,
that,
that is precisely the point that
the Milton would later in 1667,
when paradise lost is published,
he would make his poem canonical just
like the Elliot and just like the Odyssey
and the,
and the Aeneid
before anyone had actually read it meant
Milton would cert into the printed text
of his,
of his poem,
his own anticipation that his epic would
receive the same universal approbation
as homers and, and Virgil's,
uh, it's, uh, it's a,
it's a daring way to jumpstart one's
own one's own literary celebrity.
Milton Milton was continually
in a state of anticipation. Um,
and it's the,
it's this rhetoric of anticipation,
this language of looking forward that
structures all of Milton's own own
narratives about his own
literary career. And, and,
and this is a exquisitely visible to us
in the Nativity out at a very early age.
Milton bruited on his poetic vocation as
if it were an actual calling from God.
But,
but the problem of one's being called
to be a great call to be a great poet is
that one,
one may have an inkling or some sense
of a promise of a future greatness,
but nothing really to show for it
yet. Milton had, and he knew this,
he had obviously been a successful student
at the Saint Paul School in London.
And,
and then later in Cambridge at a
later in college at Cambridge University,
he had written a large handful of college
exercises and assignments in Latin and
he had obviously made a favorable
impression on his teachers,
many of whom he stayed in touch with,
uh, for years, even as a young boy,
Milton's Latin seems to have been
impeccable and he was quickly establishing
himself as one of the best Latin
nests in the country. But Milton,
it's calling,
this is what John Milton knew his
calling was to be a famous English poet,
a famous English poet,
writing in English,
a calling that he holds despite the fact
that he appears to have written next to
nothing in English verse.
All Milton has at the beginning of
this poetic career is the promise of
greatness, the anticipation of a
luminous body of, of English poetry.
Now in the first original poem that
Milton wrote in English titled Added
Vacation Exercise,
Milton and you will come to recognize
this as so unbelievably miltonic. Uh,
Milton doesn't write about love or about
death or about any of the subjects that
typically engage the youngest
practitioners of poetry.
Milton subject in his first
English poem is a, we can guess it,
it's his future literary career.
You can look at page 31 in the,
in the Hughes edition.
So Milton begins by addressing not
a fair mistress or a blooming rose,
or he doesn't even begin by
blooming, uh, by, by addressing God.
He addresses instead the English language,
hail native language.
Milton begins and then he proceeds to
set out in his heroic couplets of I ambig
Pentameter,
a map for his,
for his future career as a famous
poet. Now, when Milton publishes,
publishes this poem, he makes it
clear that it was written at age 19.
That's important to him.
Milton claims that he will one day use
the English language to express what he
calls some graver subject,
some more important subject matter,
and he proceeds to characterize what
that graver subject will will look like.
So the,
I'm looking at line 33 here,
such where the deep transported mind
may soar above the wheeling poles and it
heaven's door look in and
see each blissful deity,
how, how he before the
thunderous throne death lie.
Now the graver subject that Milton is
intending at some point to expound upon is
clearly an epic one like homer and Virgil.
Milton intends to soar above the wheeling
poles of the visible world and just
describe the otherwise invisible
comings and goings of the gods.
And of course since this is what
he would go on to do in paradise,
lost the 19 year old Milton hasn't yet
imagined that his own epic would take for
it subject to story,
a story from the Bible,
but the poetic and ambition is clearly
identifiable to us as as epic in scope.
We will hear again in Milton's
intention to write an epic in the,
in the versified letter that he writes
to his, his best friend Charles de Dadi.
Um, this is the letter to [inaudible],
uh, which Milton publishes as the, uh,
as the sixth elegy.
Uh,
that's the Latin poem that was
assigned for today's class.
So take a look at page 52 in the Hughes.
Milton Milton naturally,
uh,
wrote his friend letters in an
impeccable Latin verse. And,
and this one he seems to have composed
almost immediately after having written,
having completed the naitivity out the
letter to Dr he gives us another glimpse
of the anticipatory narrative that
Milton is sketching for his career.
Milton claims that that epic poetry
is the highest ambition for a poet.
And then again,
it goes on to explain how it is that
the epic poet should comport himself.
Uh, I love this. Oh, so this is, um,
this is Milton to,
to his best friend,
but he whose imagine
receiving a letter like this,
but he whose theme is wars and heaven
under Jupiter in his prime and Pires
Heroes and chieftains half divine.
I'll skip a little bit,
let him live sparingly,
like the same me and teacher and let herbs
furnish his innocent diet and let him
drink sober drafts from the pure spring.
Beyond this,
his youth,
the youth of the future epic poet,
his youth must be innocent of crime and
chased his conduct irreproachable and
his hands stainless.
So Milton is explaining to Tarell's dod
that if you're going to become an epic
poet, you have to start acting like
one. You have to remain celibate.
And as we will see in the coming
week, um, this is important to Milton.
You have to remain sober
and you must eat vegetarian.
Let herbs furnish his innocent diet.
And then Milton that goes on to explain
that this is exactly what homer did.
This is how homer prepared himself
to be the great, the greatest,
and the first of all epic poets.
Um, it's not an uninteresting,
I think to note that there was absolutely,
there appears to be absolutely no evidence
whatsoever available to John Milton
that homer was either veggie
vegetarian or, or, or,
or a lifelong celibate. Um, by
all accounts, Milton has just,
he's just made this up.
Um, it has led her to dia.
Dadi clearly this is
something that he wants.
He wants to believe or
that he needs to believe,
but there does seem to be evidence that
at least at this early point in Milton's
life, he's intending to remain
sexually abstinent for forever.
Um, he, he would,
he would remain a virgin
in order to prepare for and
to maintain this incredibly
important role as an epic
poet. And, and, and, and,
and as I mentioned a moment ago,
we will return to this question of what
has been interestingly and maybe rightly
called the young Milton's chastity fetish.
So,
so Milton applies to dod that he
isn't yet up to the task of, of epic,
but as he describes the naitivity
Yo that he's just written,
it's almost as if he considers it
something of a, of a mini epic. Uh,
look at, uh, this is page
one 98 in the Hughes.
I am singing the starry skies and the
hosts that saying high in the air,
that and the hosts that sing
high in the air. And the gods
and the gods that were suddenly
destroyed in their shrines.
Now there's some, we have the
trappings here of, of epic Grand Juror,
an epic subject matter that the poem on
the morning of Christ's naitivity serves
as we can think of it as
Milton's preparation for
something greater than itself.
It's a poem on which this very
young poet is cutting his teeth.
The naitivity of Christ,
as you can imagine,
was that was a popular subject for,
um,
for early 17th century poets for pious,
early 17th century poets.
Um,
nearly all of the poets that we come
now to recognize as the major religious
literary figures of, uh, of the period.
I'm like John Donne whom you may have
read an English one 25 or raw Robert
Herrick or Richard Crash.
All of these poets had tried their hand
at the poetic celebration of the birth
of Christ. And it actually,
it's instructive and you
can learn a lot by, uh,
comparing Milton's poem to those
of so many of his contemporaries.
His contemporaries are doing
a kind of thing with the,
their representation
of the birth of Christ.
That Milton seems carefully
to have avoided now most,
and you can actually imagine
without even having read them. Um,
what a lot of these poems
are like most poems,
most poets who write naitivity poems are
interested in the miracle of the Virgin
Birth, emphasizing the Virgin
Mary and the tender mother son.
Relationship between,
between Mary and Jesus Melton shows,
uh,
unusually little interest
in the miraculousness of
the conception or anything
like the domestic details of the,
of the domain of the manger scene.
The focus of the naitivity owed isn't
even really on the incarnation. Uh,
that's the,
that's the theological doctrine of,
of DV divinities descent into humanity.
How God becomes a mortal.
What Milton is primarily interested in
and his naitivity owed is the redemption,
the promised of what the promise of
what Christ's naitivity will do at some
future 0.4.
For mankind,
the birth of Jesus doesn't immediately
effect the redemption of fallen man.
But it's the moment, and this is why
it's so important to Milton this,
it's the moment at which
that promise is made.
The Nativity for Milton is
purely an anticipatory event.
It's,
it's less meaningful in itself then than
it is than it is for what it promises
for,
for the future.
Because it's not going to be until after
the negativity that we have the event
of the crucifixion. Uh, and after that,
the event of the resurrection and
finally the terrible moment of the last
judgment, which will bring the
narrative of Christian history to its,
to its ultimate close.
So the,
the satisfactions of the moment are for
Milton deferred here, and it's this,
it's something like a recognizable process
of deferral and postponement that you
will see beginning to
form themselves at the,
at the very center of Milton's
poetic imagination. Okay, let's,
let's look at the poem.
Um,
page 43 in the Hughes as,
as soon as Milton describes for us the
events in heaven that lead up to the
naitivity, he begins the, this
is the prelude of the poem.
It's broken up into two
chunks, the prelude, and then
what Milton calls the him.
He begins to third stanza of the prelude
to his poem with a plea to the heavenly
news for inspiration.
Uh,
this is line 15 page. Uh,
page 43 in the Hughes,
the poet is asking for help, uh, with,
with the composition of the poem,
say Heavenly Muse shall not they sacred
vein of four to present to the infant
God.
Hast thou no verse,
no him or solemn strain to
welcome him to this his new abode.
We're, we're struck, I think,
or at least I'm struck by the what I
find to be the oddly negative almost
scolding tone that Milton is adopting
really quite inappropriately,
I think, um, in this address to the muse,
he seems less interested in
actually praying for divine
assistance then he isn't
chiding the muse for not
having come to his aid sooner,
but we might be able to
understand some of the,
the weird anxious energy
behind the stands.
If we think of the phrase
that Milton uses here,
the phrase infant God as,
as someone who had,
um,
quickly establish himself as the most
talented Latin is probably in all of
England. Uh, Milton is
naturally, how could he not be
highly attuned to the Edom,
illogical prehistory of
the English word infant.
And our word infancy,
uh,
comes from the Latin word in farms,
which literally means not speaking Christ,
whose,
whose naitivity Milton is
honoring is still just a baby.
He isn't speaking at this moment yet.
He isn't yet producing language.
And in his role here as a,
as a mute, as an infant, Christ
is serving, I think as an,
uh,
an important function for Milton.
He serves as something like
a complicated double for the,
for the young unpublished.
And as of yet unproductive poet himself
considered that even even this early on
in his career, Milton is harboring
epic ambitions as we've seen. Um,
he is very much an infant in 16,
29.
He isn't yet able or he hasn't
yet produced epic speech.
And I think it's possible to see that
one of the purposes of this poem is,
is precisely to correct that situation.
It's one of the purposes of this poem to
allow Milton to grow out of his infancy
to incarnate or to put actually into
words the talent that he believes himself
to possess.
Now it's not until the fourth stanza of
the prelude that we can fully understand
the magnitude of the strange,
the strange anxieties here,
we can't know exactly and this is one of
the most wonderfully unsettling things
about this stanza.
We can't know exactly to whom
Milton is addressing this stands.
It would appear that Milton has
stopped addressing the Muse.
They haven't my muse and that
he has begun addressing himself,
although that's unclear,
but it may be the case that it's,
it's something like a situation in which
over the course of the previous stands
and Milton is actually usurped the role
of the Muse and has begun pro providing
something like his own inspiration.
So when the forest stands that we have,
we as readers have no idea
where we are or when it is.
The speaker of the poem imagines himself
to be speaking and it's at this point
that something quite strange happens.
Milton tells the muse or is he
telling himself, we don't know.
Milton tells someone to hurry up.
Think of this to hurry up with
the inspiration of the Ode.
Hurry up with the inspiration of the ode
because Milton can see the three wise
men bearing their gifts
as they do to flee.
Follow the star of Bethlehem
to the manger. This, uh,
this may seem to be a perfectly reasonable
vision for a poet considering himself
to be an inspired poet to
have, but it, but it's,
but there's something peculiar here.
Milton wants to beat the
three wise men to this scene.
Milton wants to arrive in Bethlehem to
hand Christ his poem to hand Christ his
poem before the wise men are able to bring
their gold and their frankincense and
their Merv a look at line 22.
See how from far upon the eastern road,
the star led wizards haste
with odors, sweet, oh run,
prevent them with thy humble load and
lay it lowly at his blessing feet.
Think of what this poem
is now asking of us.
We're being asked to accept the fiction
that Milton is having very poem laid at
the Blessitt feed of the
infant Christ Milton,
who was writing at the present moment.
The present moment of December,
1629 is claiming the capacity to arrive
at a moment in history that he has
already described as a long completed one.
Milton tells himself to run and,
and,
and naturally he would have to run fast
indeed in order to arrive at a moment in
time that had already occurred before,
before he even set out this,
this kind of temporal,
this weird temporal disjunction is
naturally an important part of the poem.
And it not only gives the poem,
it's,
it's peculiar air of something
like a conceptual timewarp,
but, but it's an important part
of Milton's profoundly, uh,
anticipatory imagination.
So Milton is struggling here to catch up
with a star led wizards who as you can
note,
um,
are already themselves hasting and he
tries to prevent them with his humble
load. We'll talk about
humble in a minute. Uh,
um, but I, I'm interested
now in the word prevent,
which for me is really the central,
uh,
the central word of this remarkable
stanza. Now, most I don't,
I don't know if Mary Hughes weighs in
on this or not a most editors of Milton.
And tell us that the word
prevent in this line retains its,
its original Latin meaning as
you can see on your handout,
it means to come before, uh,
the Latin is private era.
It means to anticipate Milton wants is
owed to make it to Bethlehem before the
three wise men do.
Now this is a form of competitiveness
with which we are all familiar.
This is the straightforward, ah, perfectly
understandable competition to be first.
Now,
now it's built ins annotators who tell
us that the word prevent means to come
before to anticipate.
And,
and on some level that obviously means
that and it got that goes without
question. But I think this
definition is also limiting. And,
and this is a phenomenon that I hope you
will come to be familiar with the good
scholars of Milton a reveal their typical
resistance to anything even remotely
interesting or alive in the text.
Surely this word prevent also has,
um,
a little bit of its modern meaning.
Um,
I think it's might actually be the
more obvious meaning, uh, which is to,
to hinder or to preclude when Milton
tells himself to prevent the starlet
wizards with by humble is also saying
that the wise men should be prevented from
making it to the manger at
all. That somehow the wise
men need to be headed off,
headed off at the pass and precluded from
presenting any gifts to the infant God
that may compete with the,
with this so called humble,
humble ode of John Milton.
Now this is a darker,
this is a darker form of
competitiveness that the kind of, uh,
of competitive and respond.
I don't know,
think of our own environment
here in the academy. Um,
that spawned by courses that, that, uh,
grade strictly on a curve, um, uh,
a type of environment where one
succeeds not merely by doing well,
but by doing better than other
people. Um, and especially, um,
in addition by preventing other
people from, from doing well,
it's a,
it's an extraordinarily
dark way to characterize the
composition and the process
of the,
of the poem.
We have a streamed image of the
composition of the poem at its at its very
outset.
And we have an image of someone writing
as if he were participating in a race
and we're reminded of the etymological
root of our modern English word,
a career, uh, Milton.
And we'll only use the word
career once in his, uh,
in his poetic of,
and it comes,
it will come pretty soon actually
in the sonnet. Number seven, uh,
the word career comes from the French.
Uh,
as you can see on the handout
[inaudible] which means a race course and
etymologically a career.
What we think of as a career isn't
simply the benign product of the gradual
development of a certain potential.
That's how we generally think of a career.
It's the outcome of a race.
It's that one's running faster
than all of the other guys.
And it's as if to have a career at all,
one has no choice but to come in first.
The desire to be first is, is,
is really central to this poem.
And it continues in this stanza have
thou thee have thou the honor first the
Lord to greet and join my voice
on to the angel choir from out.
His secret alter touched
with hallowed fire
as you may have guessed,
because you have this on your handout.
Milton is alluding here to the old,
the famous words of the Old
Testament Prophet Isaiah.
Isaiah in this passage is, is describing
a crucial moment in his career,
his career as a prophet.
The moment in which his lips are
cleansed and he is empowered,
divinely empowered to speak prophetically.
Uh,
this is the, this is the Old Testament.
These are the old testament lines.
Then flew one of the Sarah Fims unto me.
Isaiah tells us having
a live coal in his hand,
which he had taken with the
tongs from off the altar.
And he laid it upon my mouth and said,
Lo,
this hath touched thy lips and
nine iniquity is taken away.
And I sin purged. Also, I heard
the voice of the Lord saying,
whom shall I send? Who will
go for us? Then said, I,
here am I send me.
So what are we to do with
this, uh, with this illusion?
What are we to make of Milton's use
of this striking and painful image of
prophetic preparation?
Milton Milton can join his voice to the
angel choir and had the honor of being
first to greet the infant God,
but before he can actually be made
present at the actual event of the,
uh,
the need tivity he has to endure something
painful and obviously momentous from
out his secret alter
touched with hallowed fire.
The iniquity of his lips must be burned
off by alive angelic coal that the
sinfulness of his lips. And we could think
of it as the sinfulness of his voice,
his poetic voice. We'll,
we'll have to be purged.
What exactly that purgation will entail
and why Milton's voice needs to be,
needs to be purged at all.
I think these questions are really the
subject of the entire rest of the poem,
the him, what Milton calls
the humble owed that follows.
This introduction is the poem that
Milton wants to present to the Lord,
but the but the him at the same time,
it's something like the process,
the process by which Milton
is attempting to purge,
cleanse his proposed etic voice and make
it a voice that will actually be equal
to the extraordinary ambition that
Milton has for it. The him, uh,
the large part of the poem can be
divided roughly into three sections.
First I'm in the first date stands is,
um,
you have Milton describing the scene of
the negativity and the effect that the
birth of this new infant has
on the natural world. And,
and I don't have time here to
discuss this section right now,
but you've,
you've already had some encounter with
the incredibly impressive level of,
of, of ingenuity and grotesquery
in this remarkable passage.
Nature who's a personified,
a feminized, a feminized,
personified being is shamed and humiliated
when she finds herself a naked in
the, in the presence of this
new, of this new God. Jesus.
The second section runs from
Stan's is nine through 17,
and it characterizes the
song that the heavenly,
the heavenly choir sings at
the moment of the Nativity.
But when Milton describes the song of the,
uh, of, of the angelic choir, he can't,
and it's amazing.
It's as if the speaker can't seem
to focus on the event at hand. What,
what we should I think be witnessing here
is the naitivity of Christ and all of
the events,
uh,
immediately surrounding the
actual birth of the infant God.
But no sooner has Milton mentioned the
naitivity. Then he reminds himself,
and no sooner has he mentioned this,
this singing of the angelic choir.
Then he reminds himself of all
the other times that they've song,
it's something like a liner notes
or a performance history of the,
of the cosmos as greatest group ever.
I look at line one 20.
Milton writes that this choir had been
singing at the moment of creation,
not bad while the creator great,
his constellation set and the well
balanced world on hinges hung.
It's,
it's almost too much for this poet.
He's already been playing around with
the temporality of the poem as we've seen
establishing a fiction that works to,
to place him at the scene of an activity
that obviously occurs 1600 years and
change, uh, before his
own, before his own birth.
But it's almost as if Milton were tempted
now to make himself go even further
back to write a humble load that he
could place at the feet of the creator,
the Creator at the moment of the
actual creation of the entire universe,
that the stakes of coming first seem to
get, uh, are getting higher and higher.
And before long,
the speaker realizes that,
that this fantasy and it is a fantasy
that he's been engaged in is starting to
sound a little.
And even to Milton,
it's a stat sounding a little
extreme or maybe a little dangerous.
In in line one 34 Milton indicates that
this holy song has enwrapped his fancy,
that it has in some perilous
way absorbed his imagination.
For if such holy song and
wrap our fancy long time,
we'll run back and fetch the age of gold
and speckled vanity will sicken soon
and die and Lup ricin will
melt from earthly mold and
hell itself will pass away
and leave her dollar us
mansions to the piering day.
The Holy Song Milton has been describing
is beginning to look almost too
tempting even to contemplate.
There's almost a danger here and listening
to it too long or describing it into
in too much detail and the danger seems
we're at Milton thinks of as the perils
seems to involve the problem of time for
if such holy song in rap our fancy long
then then we'll mistakenly convinced
yourselves that that time could actually
run backwards and that we'd
been returned to the Golden Age,
the very first age of human history.
According to classical legend.
We, of course know as we, as we
read the prelude to this poem, that,
that this is a work consumed with,
with questions of temporal disjunction
with that problem of temporal
discontinuity.
Milton clearly wants us to know that this
naitivity owed was written by a young
Londoner in 16,
29,
but it's a poem that is at the same
time deliverable to the infant Christ by
some extraordinary violation,
of course,
of all of the established
laws of temporal sequence.
And when you reread this poem, um,
and, uh, and you look at it, uh,
in your section, perhaps you may
want to think about the tenses.
It sounds tedious, but, but it's, I,
I'm convinced that it's not tedious.
The tenses of the verbs
that Milton's using.
Milton is switching here from
present to past to future, um,
incredibly rapidly and really what the
bewildering kind of facility and it's in
some points impossible I think
for the reader to tell whether he,
the poet is discussing
something that's happening now,
something that's happened a long time ago
or something that will happen at some,
uh,
at the,
at the end of time that the matic problems
that Milton is attempting to tackle
are written into the very grammar
and the syntax of the poem.
Now, Milton understands the problems
besetting the poems, what we can think of,
the poems,
confused temporality.
He understands it's a lot better than
we do and there's a self consciousness
about the temporal strangeness of
this Poem That Leads I think, uh,
to its crisis moment. Look
at, look at stands a 16.
This is the stance of the
begins with line one 50.
Milton has just been entertaining the
glorious moment of the apocalypse at the
end of time because he's always looking
out further and further and further
ahead.
He's been doing that when we get this
line one 50 but why is this FAPE says,
no,
this must not yet be.
So the babe lies yet in smiling infancy
that on the bitter cross must redeem our
loss.
So both himself and us to glorify.
But why is this? Fate says no, this
must not yet be. So it's, it's,
it's here that we have something like a
crystallizing moment of reality testing.
Milton, he checks himself
reality, true intrudes,
and the poet has no choice but to say,
no, you've gone too far. Okay, John,
you've gone too far on your anticipation
of the future event. At the end of the,
at the end of time,
fate will permit no apocalypse before,
before its time,
before the necessary and painful
steps that have to lead up to the,
to the last judgment.
But for the ecstatic fulfillment
of all of Christian history,
the Great Christian narrative,
Jesus actually of course has to to
to grow up and lead his life and then
sacrifice that life on the bitter cross.
In eluding to the,
to the Prophet Isiah and the prelude,
Milton suggested that the iniquity
of his lips had to be purged,
purged off a burned off
with the live coal, uh,
supplied by a Sarah from
one of those or a Saraf, uh,
one of those sins.
Uh,
one of those sins I think that needs
to be purged is clearly the sin of
eagerness or over anticipation that the
drive to move ahead of oneself and the
drive to get ahead of others as we saw
Milton trying to do with the three wise
men.
These are drives that the poem seems to
be struggling to keep in check or that
Milton is representing.
The poem is struggling to keep
in check or to purge in some way,
but there's something else
that needs to be purged. Uh,
and the poem recognizes that even
more profoundly than naitivity owed is
continually presenting the
speaker with temptations,
with incitements to sin, that, that,
that need to be purged from the speakers.
Poetic Voice.
The final section of the palm presents
us with the most powerful temptation that
John Milton, uh, can confront. And we
will find that this is a problem that, uh,
continues for the rest
of his writing life. Um,
he will have to do battle with
this sim temptation forever.
And this is the temptation
offered by classical literature.
You remember that Milton had vowed to his
friend Charles Dod and the LG six that
he would,
that he would become an epic poet someday,
and that he was taking all
of the necessary steps to
transform himself into an
epic poet.
But it's strictly a Christian epic poem
that Milton seems to imagine himself as
writing. Now, he hasn't yet settled on
the, on the, on the topic of the fall,
the fall of Adam and eve from the,
from their place of bliss and
garden and the Garden of Eden.
But Milton knows that the general feeling
of the thing is of course going to be
Christian. And he's probably taking as
his model at this point, the Italian poet,
a Toric Quato Taso who,
who wrote Jerusalem delivered a Christian
a slightly earlier Christian epic
poem, Romance epic poem
that Milton greatly admired.
But Milton's also sensitive to the fact
that the very phrase Christian epic is
in some way a contradiction in terms.
The epic form is a, is a classical,
it's a pagan form.
It's a poem structured around
the interaction between
human beings and the and
an entire Pantheon of pagan deities and
to write any kind of epic at all might
very well seem to be embracing and in
an inappropriate sensual inappropriately
sensual paganism at the expense of
the higher discipline of monotheistic,
good old fashioned monotheistic Chris
Christianity and, and the Ode to the form,
the form that this poem is written in
[inaudible] is a pagan form invented by
the Greek poet Pindar to express the
sublimity of emotion arising from a
contemplation of the actions of the gods.
Now in writing to,
in writing in these John was, Milton is,
is of course confronted with a dilemma.
He's a humanist scholar.
He is more steeped in the century,
was beauty of classical literature,
the classical tradition than probably
anyone else of his generation.
Since he was an unusually small lad,
he had been mainlining,
a Greek and Roman poetry,
the the language of homer.
And Virgil and if Pindar and have often
had become an inextricable part of,
of his literary imagination of and
of his consciousness in general.
But Milton was also beginning
to develop in this period, uh,
a much more strict to much more
disciplined religious temperament.
He was beginning to join ranks with those
early 17th century English Protestants
who imposed upon themselves rigorous
and strict codes of behavior and self
denial and who are increasingly being
called by their enemies puritans.
And it's possible that the very idea of
a puritan poet presented Milton with,
with what may have felt like it,
like an insoluble conflict. It,
it's possible that the
Milton would continue. Well,
if,
if Milton were to continue this
cultivation of a poetic career career,
he would clearly have to purge. This is,
this is the miltonic logic at this stage.
He would have to purge his poetic
Voice of the sin and the taint of Pagan
antiquity. If he was going to become
a specifically Christian poet,
he would have to expelled from his system.
The sensual world of classical learning
that for him was at the very core of his
being.
And it's precisely a silencing
of classical literature
that Milton is attempting
to affect here with this scene of the
flight of the Pagan Gods at the naitivity
of Christ.
Milton is also depicting a scenario that
I think on some level he's hoping will
occur within himself.
We have the silencing,
not just to any literature here,
but, but of Pagan literature.
It's now the pagan deities who
have turned into infant gods.
They have been, Eh, Milton is, uh,
is narrating or representing the
process by which they are silenced.
They're rendered speechless
or dumb, and the poem, uh,
effects this process in order to give
someone else an opportunity to speak.
Milton calls upon a whole range
of, of violence, exciting,
militaristic images and
set pieces to describe the,
the triumph of Christ over the
petty gods of paganism. But this,
this routing of the gods
brings with it a certain cost.
Something is lost here as
well. Uh, look at line one 81.
These are without hands down. These are
the these for me, these are the best,
the best lines in the poem,
the lonely mountains or,
and the resoundingly
shore of Voice of weeping,
heard and loud lament from haunted spring.
And Dale edged with poplar peo,
that parting genius.
It's with sighing sent with flour and
in woven tresses torn the nymphs in
twilight shade of Tangle
thickets. Mourn. It's,
it's here in this stands a
field with the resounding, uh,
voices of weeping and lament that we
realized that something more is going on
than merely a routing of the pagan gods.
Something more even than Milton's pious
triumph over his classical literary
imagination.
Uh,
suddenly the literary genre that Milton
writing is writing in is no longer this
triumphant classical owed.
You have an elegy here,
a beautiful and lament for
something or someone lost.
And, and, and we have to ask ourselves,
could this be a paradise lost?
We hear a clear morning for,
for those pagan beings who are forced to
depart because of the violent onset of
Christianity.
When Milton writes that the
parting genius is with signs sent,
he means the genius Loci or the
the local spirit of the place,
the natural spirit of a place.
Those beneficence beings that pay pagans
had believed inhabited certain woods
and streams.
But the parting genius is also a
part of Milton's own genius. His,
his literary genius,
that aspect of his literary career and
his literary expertise that has been
nourished and fed,
um,
lovingly fed by,
by classical literature.
The conflictedness that Milton
is encapsulating here is, uh,
is probably most intense
in the last lines of this,
of this wonderful stanza with flour
and woven tresses torn the nymphs in
twilight shade of tangled thickets.
Mourn this,
and I'm almost done here.
The densely tangled thicket of costs,
clustered consonants in this, in this
amazing couplet is a signal to us of the,
of the weight of the import
of this terrible event.
That these are difficult
lines physically to read.
And they may very well be the most
painful lines in the, in the entire poem.
From an emotional perspective,
it's, it's one thing, uh,
for the evil pagan deities
like Mo lock and Payor, uh,
to be forced into hell by the
newly newly born Christ, uh,
who are they to us? We find it
difficult to be whale their absence,
but the Nymphs,
the Nymphs in all of their sensuous
beauty with flour and woven dresses,
they have to experience the same fate.
And I think it's impossible not to wince
when we imagine the painful tearing of
the nymphs tresses.
Their hair gets caught on the tangled
thickets of the forest as the abandoned
the cloud as they are forced to abandon
the classical corners of Milton's
literary imagination.
That the Lhi tone of some of the,
of this final section of the poem
should give us some clues to the type of
victory over paganism that Christ's
birth is actually heralding here. Um,
how new, uh, will this new
world order actually be?
We may imagine that hence forth now that
he has written is Nate naitivity owed.
Milton has fully explored
expunged from his literary system,
that youthful attachment to the
pagan classics. But of course,
no object of our love this,
this is true of all of us can ever be
rejected with an absolute finality.
The explosion of Paganism described in
the Nativity Nativity owed is a scene
that Milton we'll return to
and return to again and again,
and in many ways it will be Christianity's
triumph over paganism and all of the
pain that that triumph produces that
will become the hidden subtext of,
of many of Milton's greatest works.